at least five palestinians have been
killed and eight others injured during
confrontations with israeli forces in
the occupied west bank
palestinian sources say the israeli
forces stormed several villages in
janine and ramallah
surrounded houses and opened fire early
in the morning israel says that soldiers
raided five villages to arrest who they
call hamas operatives live now to west
jerusalem harry fawcett is there for us
harry
what more do we know about this latest
violence
well certainly the
idea of israeli raids in the occupied
west bank is something that takes place
on a very regular basis but not usually
ending in this level of of violence and
death what we know from the israeli
military is that they began
their operation
in the north of the west bank in and
around janine there were several arrests
that took place but in one village the
village of burkin there was a gun battle
that eventuated in the death of at least
one palestinian man a 22 year old the
governor of janine saying that two
people two palestinians were killed uh
during the course of that gun fight and
then later in the early hours of sunday
uh there was the
separate operation around the village of
and in that
three palestinians were killed
the israelis say that they were breaking
up hamas or were seeking out a hamas
terror cell that was in the process of
plotting an attack
inside israel there's the reports coming
through army radio and in that second
gun fight there was a senior hamas
figure killed ahmad zaran who had been
on the run for some time and had been
hunted by israeli forces for some time
so what's led up to all of this harry
uh well certainly the israelis say that
this was an operation they'd been
carrying out for some days at least if
not weeks the israeli prime minister
naftali bennett on his way to new york
to speak at the united nations general
assembly uh he said that this was a
terror cell and that it was in the
process of planning an attack
as i say this one figure ahmed zahran he
was being
very much he'd been in the sights of the
israelis for some time there was
pressure being inflicted on his family
eight arrests and detentions recently
including that of his wife so there had
been some kind of lead up to this
as far as hamas is concerned
it is saying that the blood of its
martyrs as it called them would continue
to fuel the resistance against israel
that criticized the palestinian
authority for its security cooperation
with israel the question now i think
going forward is uh how this will be uh
received both in the occupied west bank
whether there could be further violence
there or indeed as we saw with the
arrests of the prisoners recently the
palestinian-islamic jihad prisoners
we saw
rockets fired out of gaza in response
after those arrests so i think there
will be some attention on gaza even as
there are reports of a potential
prisoner exchange being negotiated
between hamas and the israelis this
obviously will be a point of tension
these these deaths overnight al
jazeera's harry fossett reporting live
from west jerusalem harry many thanks